>> Bret: SOMETHING IN THE WATER
WITH THE TWINS.
GOOD EVENING, WELCOME TO
WASHINGTON.
I'M BRET BAIER.
BREAKING TONIGHT, A DRASTIC AND
DESPERATE DETERIORATION OF THE
SITUATION IN AFGHANISTAN.
7,189 DAYS AFTER U.S. AND
AFGHANISTAN FORCES TOOK BACK
CONTROL OF THE SOUTHERN CITY OF
KANDAHAR FROM THE TALIBAN,
TALIBAN FIGHTERS HAVE NOW TAKEN
CONTROL AGAIN OF THE SECOND
LARGEST CITY IN THE COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO AUTHORITIES ON THE
GROUND.
AND TODAY, 19 YEARS 8 MONTHS AND
6 DAYS LATER, AFGHAN OFFICIALS
AND U.S. MILITARY LEADERS ARE
CONCERNED THE CAPITAL CITY OF
KABUL COULD BE NEXT AS CONSIDERS
WITHDRAWAL TONIGHT THE PENTAGON
IS SENDING BACK IN 3,000
ADDITIONAL FORCES AND EVEN MORE
TO EVACUATE AMERICANS AS THE
TALIBAN CLOSE IN ON KABUL.
TWO OTHER MAJOR AFGHAN CITIES
HER ROTH AND GAUZY QUICKLY TELL
TO THE TALIBAN TODAY.
LUCAS TOMLINSON IS AT THE
PENTAGON WITH THE LATEST.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
SOME THOUSAND MARINES DEPLOYING
OF A WARNING THE AFGHAN CAPITAL
COULD FALL TO THE TALIBAN IN THE
NEXT 90 DAYS.
HERE IS HOW JOHN KIRBY DESCRIBED
THE MISSION.
>> THIS IS A TEMPORARY MISSION
WITH A NARROW FOCUS.
AS WITH ALL DEPLOYMENTS OF OUR
TROOPS INTO HARM'S WAY OUR
COMMANDERS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
SELF-DEFENSE ANY ATTACK ON THEM
CAN'T WILL BE MET WITH A
FORCEFUL AND APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE.
>> 8,000 U.S. TROOPS TOTAL WILL
BE DEPLOYING THOUGHT TONAL
AFGHANISTAN BUT TO THE MIDDLE
EAST AS WELL.
IN ADDITION TO THE 3,000 3,000
SOLDIERS AND MARINES GOING TO
KABUL.
FORT BRAGG DEPLOYING TO KUWAIT
TO BE HELD IN RESERVE IN CASE
THEY ARE NEEDED IN AFGHANISTAN.
THEY ARRIVE NEXT WEEK.
1,000 ADDITIONAL SOLDIERS WILL
BE DEPLOYED TO QATAR
INTERPRETERS HELPED THE U.S.
MILITARY ALONG WITH THEIR
FAMILIES, REFUGEES FLEEING THE
WAR TORN COUNTRY THIS AS THE
TALIBAN HAS BEEN ON LIGHTNING
OFFENSE IN THE LAST WEEK.
TONIGHT THEY CONTROL 12.
THE LATEST KANDAHAR CITY THE
SECOND LARGEST CITY IN
AFGHANISTAN THE SPIRITUAL HOME
TALIBAN FELL TODAY.
STATE DEPARTMENT ORDERING OUT OF
THE COUNTRY.
REMAIN OPEN FOR NOW WITH
ESSENTIAL PERSONNEL ONLY.
DEPLOYMENT OF TROOPS.
>> ARE YOU TELLING ME THAT THE
MARINES AND SOLDIERS STRAPPING
ON GOING TO CAB BULL THIS ISN'T
COMBAT.
>> LUCAS, WHAT I'M TELLING YOU
AND I SAID IT BEFORE THEY WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
THEY WILL BE ARMED.
OF COURSE THEY'RE GOING FOR A
SECURITY MISSION.
>> WHEN I ASKED KIRBY IF THE
U.S. MILITARY WOULD BE FULLY
WITHDRAWN FROM THE COUNTRY BY
THE END OF AUGUST HE SAYS THAT
TIMELI